so this woman named Samantha castanza
she talks about she recently went on a
first date with a man she met on an app
so he paid for drinks and a few days
later he messaged her messaged her
messaged her that he'd like to see her
again but she did not feel the same so
clearly his ego got in the way and he
asked her if um she could venmo him
money for the drinks that he bought her
luckily she ignored the request blocked
him and she said my time and energy is
not refundable oh um how dare he right
what what I know I mean can you can she
invoice him for the dry cleaning for the
blouse she wore to the date can we start
if you're going to start it honey we'll
finish it